hey everyone
god's brain
a nervous system analogy
for the nature of reality
some of you may know that
i've been fascinated with
the nervous system i've been fascinated
with
consciousness i've been fascinated with
the synthesis of science and
spirituality
i've been fascinated with metaphysics
and i've been disseminating
these artistic synthesis and
distillations
on the nature of those subjects
and
this one has so many strong
analogies on the
macro and the micro level that i'm
pumped
to share with you with great visuals
so let's jump in on the
macro level we can
conceptualize what we can call
god or what we call source or what we
call
infinity
we can conceptualize that
as god's brain
and that includes this
creation as one of its
many expressions
and why i write self-realization
there with god's brain is that's what
the
inward path
leads one to realize is that
the diamond necklace is already around
their neck
that awareness is
it we are the awareness
of god
and that is shared
and then on the micro level we can think
about
us individually
as human neurons
and
that as self-actualization
because the
individual neurons
are part of different structures
inside of the brain
and they undergo different contributory
processes as well
and god in this case
would be something like the integral
the integration
of all of the infinitesimal data
of all sentience
of all awareness of all consciousness
of all existence
and so our creation is one
of many that are being
in that integral of god's brain
and that would be across all different
creations is what we would add
into that integration into that
summation
all right such a cool analogy so pumped
for this
okay so
as you can see there there's the actual
anatomical
layout of that central nervous system
and peripheral
nervous system and there
is also a neuron there
for you to check out
so
i made some props
okay
i'm going to
first well i made one of the two props
i'm gonna make an analogy first
so
the analogy that we're going to draw for
number one
is the multiverse and so
what we have here is we have a bitter
melon
which is
a fascinating
secretion from earth and
it tastes interesting
but you can tell that on this
is many different
protrusions
right it's protruding out in many
different
little
pieces and you can kind of see them
right protruding out
okay so now that was
the bitter melon now we have the visual
on that
and now similarly
i want us to take a look at
this which is funny it's it's what i i
actually made this
um it's kind of funny little arts and
crafts
for the multiverse
okay so
that can be thought of as god's source
dao
brahman and what you have here is you
have this paper towel core
and eric weinstein in his
geometric unity was a big influence
on this and so
what's going on here is you have a bunch
of different
pin colors on the bottom you have white
then you have red then you have orange
then you have yellow then you have green
then you have this light blue
this dark blue and this black okay
and so this is
something that we're going to have to
use our imagination for because this
needs to be infinite
so this would be infinite
and so there's all these infinite
expressions and what's happening is
these different colors
represent different creation designs
and so the quote big
bang to recursion
the oroboros
is one type of creation design
so we have to use our imagination and
[Music]
imagine what else we would make
as
creation designs for us to immerse
ourselves in as
sentient agents as awareness as
consciousness
to experience those
many different ways for us to do that
process use your imagination
and so all the different colors are
different creation designs
and that similar colors
you know especially up here like maybe
this light blue
and this dark blue are more
similar those are more similar
worlds than for example
maybe that dark blue
and the red
those are much further away from one
another
okay now
so
if we move on to the second point
what we'll see
so we'll see something very special
in number two with universes because
these greens
we can hypothesize our
our universe
and the different worlds
in our universe
and the idea of
chimps again evolving to
artificial general intelligence agi
is one type
so even in our universe
there are other types
of evolutionary processes or sentience
awareness consciousness
experiences its creation
and as you can tell right there
one of them is a circle
[Music]
okay so why is that one circled because
that
one green that has the circle
in this case is earth
okay so out of all of these
creation designs in the multiverse
that is again infinite
this one little tiny
design is earth
is where we're at
and so it's very humbling
and it's also important to
stretch our imagination
into that god's brain
into that source into that infinity
with all of these different creation
designs
and again quote big bang
to recursion is
one type of design and so is these types
of
vehicles that we use here with
these two eyes and four limbs and
being carbon based and dna
encoded is but one of so many
different
infinite flavors
for sentience or consciousness or
awareness to experience
it's fascinating okay so
you can make this at home if you'd like
again just a paper towel core with
some multi-colored pins
poked through
but i but i don't know how to
uh grow the bitter melon
i don't know if uh los angeles i don't
even know if
we can grow maybe in the central valley
right maybe
but because it does produce so much
agriculture there
and that leads us to the chapter 9
graphic on consciousness
this is the chapter 9 in high level
perception
our first visual synthesis
and book and you can find that link in
the bio
as well and so this chapter 9 graphic is
very
near and dear to my heart because what
we're starting to do is we're starting
to really sort of see okay
well we have we have this god's brain
on the macro and then
it has all of these different creation
designs
and then we can think about even those
creation designs as having their own
local version of a brain
so in a sense here you can see it's like
a
planetary brain
so you can think about it like 8
billion neurons
humans
and the integration the integral
the summation of their
sentience of their awareness of their
consciousness
of their experience
so now we're starting to get interest in
places
and you can also include the
approximately 10 million
species on the planet in this summation
and just the entirety of the creation
design
in the summation if you would like now
there is something extremely profound of
course
regarding the quote
individual neuron experience
and that there are many nuances
to that and that's in point
three
so each neuron
is a human we can think of neurogenesis
as birth we can think of
neurodegeneration
as death so again on that
planetary brain level a new neuron
neurogenesis
being the birth and then a
neurodegeneration
being a death now
this is quite interesting because we've
been doing many videos on the direct
path on our channel and that means the
direct path to self-realization
of that god brain
of that source of that infinity and
one of the best modalities that we've
been
sharing in order to
self-realize is
creating the juxtaposition
the juxtaposition is between bare
or pure or empty awareness without
coloration
versus awareness that is
colored and by colored we mean colored
by
thoughts emotions feelings
beliefs and objects okay
so that's colored awareness and now we
created juxtaposition
between that and pre-coloration
awareness bear pure empty awareness
and usually the way that we describe
that
and we'll connect this to neurons in a
moment as well
which is fascinating i love doing this
so
this right here is a
paper that
has no words so this is paper that is
bare pure empty awareness
now this is paper
that has words so this is
awareness that has coloration
so this is awareness with coloration
because it's paper with words
and this is paper without words so this
is awareness without coloration
quite simple
in modernity
we also use this example which is that
screen it's the screen on the phone
it's the screen on the computer
it's the screen on the tv it's the
screen on the tablet
they're all over now and so
now that we have billions of people
around the planet that have
the screen it becomes easy to use this
analogy as well so the screen
again we're creating a juxtaposition
here
the screen
pre-coloration is the way it is right
now
now as soon as you unlock the screen
and you begin browsing applications
getting onto social media
watching videos going to texts and phone
calls and emails
all of that is coloration so that's the
thoughts feelings emotions beliefs and
objects
with awareness so if
we pass just a little bit of time
practicing
with both the
looking at the blank
sheet of paper as well as the blank
screen and we
create the juxtaposition
between aiming to tap into
our awareness and consciousness creating
that juxtaposition before coloration and
trying to
read baseline to understand that that is
home and that that is eternal and that
is infinite
and that its nature is bliss and peace
and that it's been here forever and it's
going to continue
exploring different creation designs
forever
that's what we've been teaching on the
direct path so you can go and watch
those videos if you would like and the
way that that
deeply relates to neuroscience and this
analogy the nervous system analogy
for the nature of reality god's brain
i love it is that bear awareness or pure
awareness or empty awareness can be
thought of the neuron
pre-modulation
and the neuron that is
being modulated
is colored that is coloration
so whether we'll get into this here in a
moment as we get into number four on
communication
but whether it is
having a neuromodulation
or neurotransmission the effect
of inhibition or of excitation
that that is all quote neuronal
coloration and
the pure bear empty
awareness is before that
so hopefully that helps with this
juxtaposition in the analogy
and another way to think about it which
is very profound
given the fact that these beautiful eyes
are literally
the nervous system you know jutted out
and experiencing
the creation
so the analogy as well would be
something like
pure bear empty awareness
or god's brain is visible in
every single one of our pupils
so if you look at just the pupil of
every single human's eye
you're gonna see the same black
pupil and that
black pupil
that is god that black
pupil that is source that black pupil
that is infinity that black pupil is
eternal it is infinite
it's been here exploring creations
it will continue being here exploring
creations
and the sooner that you recognize that
truly
realize it and embody it the sooner you
get that
the more you'll have bliss and peace on
a 24-hour
basis not just five minutes
of bliss and peace every single day and
that being
fine you can have 24 hours of bliss and
peace because it's your nature
you deserve it so if you want more on
that you can watch the direct path
videos where we unpack that more and now
if we juxtapose that the pupils
as the pure bear empty awareness with
the irises
the irises are the coloration that is
around the pupil
and those irises are beautifully
different
across people
and that's really cool and so now you
can sort of see the oh that's kind of
cool so that's like a unique
neuron that's like a unique
self-actualization
each unique iris coloration is like that
but that pupil that pupil itself
is shared our awareness
our consciousness is shared
the sooner you realize that
the more awakened and enlightened and
prosperous
and abundant and flourishing our
civilization
will be in a direct
harmony with the original living wisdom
of planet earth
number four communication
i'm pumped for this one
so i would like to
give credit to
andrew huberman
what an incredible science communicator
over at
stanford and really grateful
to have gotten to collaborate with him
at
the brain mind summit
he's very strong
at communicating the
very complex neuroscience
and so uh i put his
link to his instagram
in the bio check that out he's
doing a great job at communicating via
videos
on there and also he has recently also
launched
a youtube channel which i highly
recommend going and subscribing to that
link
is in his instagram bio right now and
that's
what you see there regarding the
image that first image
where it says number one
neurotransmitters and number two
neuromodulators that is
specifically his drawing and explanation
and then there's another image later
that we're using
um from his work uh so credit to him and
also just
just go and check it out it's so good so
number four is communication
and the whole lab by the way the whole
huberman lab is great
number four communication
so the
very cool analogy to start here
is the synapse and so
that synapse as you can see below that
first graphic are those
the graphic of that's
our interview that we did with adelita
and you can see there's you know there's
two humans
and then there's the synapse which is
that space between the neurons
the postsynaptic the presynaptic and the
postsynaptic
two neurons synapse space between
it's fascinating because you look over
at
the neurons next to it and you're like
oh my goodness that analogy is really
interesting
and you know
i'm sitting there as the interviewer and
so
you know i'm just i'm listening to what
our guest is
sharing on the program and so there's
almost a
there's almost a neuro transmission
that's occurring
it's very much like
glutamate the excitatory
neurotransmission that's occurring from
our guest
and for myself as well as for the for
the audience
and for here it's happening here and
then it's going through
to you and exciting
you there which is fascinating
how we can view that style of
neurotransmission
and so we have that analogy
and again it's really interesting
because that sort of
neurotransmission is a very kind of
one-on-one
level and it can be excitatory
again using glutamate or it can be
inhibitory using gaba
and you can kind of think of it
excitatory and inhibitory
in a sense you can think about it like
are you more service to self
and self dealing or are you more service
to other
are you serving the well-being and the
flourishing
of all or do you have that
constrained self-interest and ego
and so that can maybe be a way to think
about neuro transmission
when you're out and sharing with people
and speaking are you using logos are you
using the word
like glutamate and exciting
and creating more service to others and
more abundance and prosperity and
flourishing for all
or are you using gaba and are you
inhibitory on the
maybe service to self
and there's many ways to sort of take
this analogy as well because you can
also potentially think about
the inability in a sense
to have high emotional intelligence
and if there's a
setting that is very quiet
and serene and you come in there with
glutamate excitatory
that that may not actually be right for
that setting at that time
and so there's many nuances and
analogies that can be drawn here and
this would be something interesting
potentially for
the viewers to continue doing would be
continuing to find
fascinating ways to analogize the
humans as neurons of the planetary brain
engaging in neurotransmission and the
neural modulation
would be something like a
a broader communication so
in this sense it would be like a group
of neurons
maybe it's a a company of
five or ten people that are
disseminating some sort of
in this case maybe dopamine or serotonin
or acetylcholine
and they're creating that
neuromodulation
onto a larger circuit
of neurons
and so that can be maybe be thought more
like a
group email as
a way of viewing it
and then we can explore things like
plasticity
and we can see how things like the whole
neurons that fire together wire together
can be thought of as in communication
that in that example with
we were showing a little bit ago with
someone like
having adelita on the show that
the more that i would undergo a process
of creating with her
that our neuronal connection would
strengthen
which is fascinating
and then you can think about it also
as the opposite as pruning because
if maybe somebody that we had in the
very
more early more formative days of the
show
three years ago maybe for one of the
first couple dozen episodes
and i have not spoken with them
in those three years because we've both
been off creating our things
and that connection in a sense has
pruned out
and so it's fascinating to think about
this
from that perspective as well so many
analogies here
on this one and then augmentation so
we're experiencing the whole brain
computer interface
bci era
and this
is very much like a hive mind idea
in the most prosperous collective
intelligence
sense and so sort of being able to tap
into that 8 billion
neuron collective intelligence
at a hive mind level at a greater
bandwidth
for creator consciousness to manifest
more beauty more creativity
more prosperity
and also augmenting ailments and
maladies
diseases pathologies of the
nervous system as well so
that's number four communication
okay cool cool this is that other
andrew huperman graphic here
number five's clustering
and so
again if you kind of refresh your memory
a little bit here with this graphic
right and you think about it okay so
that planetary brain the eight billion
neurons okay all right so
and that's approximately an order of
magnitude approximately
less than what we hypothesize
approximately 86
billion neurons in the each human
brain and so now if you sort of take
that right and you're looking at it and
you're like okay well
well where are those neurons on the
planet
right where are the neurons on the
planet
where are they yeah they're the humans
but
where location wise are they
and then that's where you sort of get to
this clustering and you start thinking
oh that's a dope analogy
when i was first watching this video by
andrew and it hit me i was like oh my
god that's fascinating so
the metros the metropolises of the
planet
right the new york cities and the los
angeles is in the londons and the lagos
and the shanghai and the berlins and
etc
those are like the hand
and the most rural places
that don't have as much population
density
are like the back
and so if you take a look at andrew's
graphic here
that neuronal
density of touch sensitivity
on your hand
is significantly higher you can see
there just on
two inches there there's so many more
of these sensitive points
whereas if you take a look at something
like your back on that 12 inch
slab there's much less
sensitivity and you can think about that
logically as well it makes sense
evolutionarily that
you don't really need that much
touch sensitivity on your back but you
definitely need touch sensitivity here
on your hands and so in a sense
it's fascinating so you can start
thinking about it that way and you're
like oh
crap so like the metros
of the planet are kind of like the hands
because they have these massive
neuronal clusters
that are all undergoing
neurotransmission and neural modulation
in those metros at very fast rates
and then you juxtapose that with sort of
like a slower
rate of neurotransmission and
neuromodulation that's happening in
rural places
you know places that only have you know
10 000 people in a city
stuff like that
and then you can also think about in
number five clustering you can think
about the
the pfc the prefrontal cortex you can
maybe
think about that like the illuminati
just fascinating analogies
to make here because the sort of
executive functioning
of the planetary
brain
is in very many ways directed by the
2 200 billionaires on the planet the 225
000 ultra high net worth people on the
planet
the fortune 500 ceos
the united nations general assembly the
usa congress all the people that gather
at the world economic forum davos all
this type of stuff
and so if we begin thinking about that
like a prefrontal cortex it's like
well are those people living
in egoic levels of consciousness or
have they ever tasted non-duality before
because that might actually be our most
upstream malady that we face
literally the people that are in
the prefrontal cortex the neurons that
are in the prefrontal cortex
of civilization may have
never tasted ego death
that in itself
should be enough to convince us that
we must hone in on
the awakening and enlightenment
of the neurons in the prefrontal cortex
again the ones with the most executive
functioning
again likely the most upstream problem
is the neurons in the pfc having egoic
levels of consciousness that are more
about self-interest self-dealing
rather than being in service to others
because
the other is actually the self
the one infinite creator god source
so once people awaken to and hopefully
analogies like this that help them
realize oh
neurons of god's brain that's what this
is
oh we're all god
[Music]
because once you get to that level
service to others
becomes natural it becomes the only
thing that channels through you
is to be an authentic genuine loving
compassionate
service to others to the well-being and
prosperity
and abundance of society
and then you can potentially think about
the limbic
aspects to our
neural infrastructure
like sheeple and in a sense that would
mean something like
in many ways where i was as well
before
having underwent so many years of being
dedicated relentlessly to seeking
truth and having it yield
piercing the veil of reality or
recognizing that diamond necklace are on
my neck
or recognizing that this is all the one
infinite creator expressing itself
oh my goodness was i easily
triggered and manipulated by propaganda
and all this type of stuff and so we
have to recognize that maybe the neurons
that are in the limbic infrastructures
of the planetary brain
are sheeple
and that we also have to do high quality
neurotransmission and high quality
neural modulation
to the limbic infrastructures
to help also
those neurons undergo the process of
piercing the veil
and recognizing that they are a part of
god's brain
that they are that that you are that
that i
am that that we are that we are god we
are
source we are the one infinite creator
expressing itself and this is one
expression of it
this creation is
everyone deserves bliss and peace
24 hours a day not just for five minutes
and another example here in the
clustering
is tumors and this is another sort of
interesting
analogy because sort of these egoic
levels of consciousness that cluster
together as neurons
can be thought of as tumors
and that
it's up to us to create
the neurotransmission neuromodulation
and the eradication of the pathology
and the healing of it to neurogenesis
and this type of stuff that enables
that cluster to
heal
as much as we can and become augmented
now there may be times when they have to
be removed
right the tumors and uh
we can also in a sense
do our best to have preventative
right health care which is preferable
rather than
having the pathology in such a late
stage like a tumor
and then being like oh crap now i have
to remove it
instead you can we can identify our
maladies in the most
upstream and then even before they get
anywhere near
a bad downstream pathology we can make
the proper tweaks along the way at the
intracellular level inside of the cells
before they become dysfunctional that's
the future of healthcare
is retaining that 18 year old
homeostatic capacity forever
and you getting to decide if you ever
want to
you know that's the longevity escape
velocity
great and number six
oh man i'm pumped for this one
dreams uh okay
so
we have to recognize the as above so
below
aspect to this and the recursive
aspect to this the same way
that we dream for a third of our lives
we sleep for a third of our lives and we
dream for a good chunk of that sleeping
some of us more than others and some
even lucid dream
right lucid dreaming being when you take
complete free will control of your
dreamed environment
it's so fascinating we literally
simulate realities in our dream
and we immerse ourselves in the first
person perspective in those simulated
realities
how is this not already that of god's
brain
a simulated reality in god's brain
a first person immersion into
the simulated reality of a dream in
god's brain
[Music]
and that's recursive the procedure calls
on itself
the procedure of god's dream
calls on the individual neurons
in the dream to undergo a process of
dreaming
in their sleep for a third of their
lives
and virtual reality is an awakening
mechanism
to this because what's going to happen
in these
especially in 2020s and even in the
2030s
these next two decades oh my goodness
if you haven't seen ready player one yet
go watch it
our immersion into indistinguishable
virtual realities in the first person
perspective is going to be a massive
awakening mechanism for us to realize
that this already
is the virtual reality this already
is the simulation
and that that's what these realities are
these realities are
simulations of god
of infinity of source
and they've been happening eternally
they will continue happening forever
there is no end to our exploration
the awareness the consciousness
the beingness the very is-ness the very
i
am-ness is eternal
it's bliss in peace and it's doing this
exploration
we can never come to the end of
phenomenology we can never come to the
end of experience
and that's why the vr is going to be
acting like a major
awakening mechanism especially once you
synthesize the brain computer interfaces
with them and you synthesize artificial
general intelligence
and that's what we hypothesize is that
transcension hypothesis
where we go into these indistinguishable
virtual worlds as the quote
next cycle of consciousness exploring
infinity
and that's why roger penrose who won the
nobel prize in physics in 2020 believes
in cyclic cosmology
even the world's most cutting edge
physicists
are beginning to believe what the
perennial
spiritual wisdoms of the planet have
been
saying with the oroboros the snake
eating its tail
i love that point six so awesome
so you can ask yourself why injure
another
neuron of the same body
doesn't make any sense
so even that simple understanding
of oh yeah this is all god's brain
why would i ever hurt myself
another neuron that is myself why would
i do that
and don't forget you're not just the
neuron but you're also god's brain
this is very important right the
self-actualization
is the fullest artistic expression of
the neuron
of the human neuron but
also the self-realization is that inward
process of the neuron realizing that it
is
god's brain and that this
is all god's brain
and that realization
brings a tremendous amount of
peace of bliss of
joy and of the absolute highest
morality
and if you do things like visualize all
8 billion neurons
undergoing their own unique processes of
realizing that they are god's brain
that's what is meant by the sufi
metaphysic
that's the unity of all finding and so
that would be
all eight billion neurons in their own
unique findings of
the fact that they are god's brain
and through the integral
and you have the summation of
neurons piercing the veil of their
existence on this planet and
awakening to the fact that they are
god's brain
it is hard to tell you're in the ocean
when you're a fish
wake up you're already in the ocean
this is god's brain you are god
you are a neuron expression
in god that is you that is me that is
all of us
we've been doing this we're going to
keep doing this earth's brain
is just one creation design
back to my arts and crafts project
so
just that right there
is the earth brain
so again this is the infinite multiverse
and this one little
pinhead is that integration
of earth's brain and this is just one
creation design
and what you can say is god's brain
is the integration of all
creation designs
all infinite creation designs
and the integration of that is god's
brain
cool glad we got a chance to
do this nervous system analogy for the
nature of reality
it's a very profound one
again god's brain on the macro level
self-realization on the micro level the
human neuron is the self-actualization
god is the integral of all sentience
across all creations
that multiverse the infinite expressions
those different colors being creation
designs
big bang to recursion is just one type
the universes and how our
universe were the greens and then our
one little green pinhead was earth
chimps to agi is just one type
this chapter 9 graphic on consciousness
and we're going to keep making really
awesome art like this
that helps explain the complex concept
simply
humans being neurons neurogenesis being
birth neurodegeneration being death
pre-mode neuron is
bare pure empty awareness like your
pupils
and then modulated neurons are colored
neurons like your awareness with
thoughts emotions feelings beliefs
and objects like your irises
communication again that synapse
between neurons just like the space
between humans
transmission modulation
plasticity augmentation
clustering
like metros rural pfc limbic
tumors and dreams simulated realities
first person immersion as above so below
recursion
beautiful god's brain is the integration
of all creation designs
boom love it
love you thank you so much for tuning in
super appreciate you
i would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
how do you feel about this how does this
land
did it augment your understanding
if so let me know
did it help you self-realize that would
be awesome
love to hear from you also if so like
the video
also subscribe if you haven't share the
video
really trying to grow the reach of these
profound messages
to more people so many people don't know
about us yet but are looking for exactly
this type of content
so share us with those people please
again go follow andrew huberman in
the hubermann lab over at stanford
they're awesome the links in the bio
below
they make great content
and find more analogies like this
douglas hofstetter called analogy the
core of cognition
right on the map of the
continental united states analogy isn't
delaware analogy
is the interstate system
analogy is such a massive core of
cognition
so find more analogies
that enable us to explain the nature of
our reality
in explain like i'm five
very friendly visual ways
that can make it easier for people to
self-realize
make it easier for people to
self-actualize make it easier for
us to enhance our neural transmission
and our neural modulation
and to
create a more flourishing
abundant prosperous future
and sense-making
that's it self realize self actualize
you are god's brain i am god's brain
we're all god's brain
we have eternally been doing this we're
going to keep doing it
we are the one infinite creator
expressing itself
i love you thanks for tuning in god's
brain
the nervous system analogy for the
nature
of reality
wow